maintenant est-ce que la région de
montréal est en surchauffe d'un secteur
résidentiel en septembre 2019 les ventes
de maisons unifamiliales et de condos à
montréal ont augmenté de 15 % par
rapport à l'an dernier et de 11 % pour
les plex les inscriptions en vigueur ont
cependant chuté de 15 % pour les maisons
unifamiliales de 29% pour les condos et
de 17% pour les plex julie saucier est
présidente et chef de la direction de
l'association professionnelle des
courtiers immobiliers du québec bonsoir
madame soucier pan soir quand on dit le
mot sur chaud oui ça veut dire quoi
qu'est-ce que marché en surchauffe et
enfin un marché en surchauffe
c'est vraiment quand le nombre de ventes
de résidences est plus élevé que les
inscriptions donc l'offre est beaucoup
plus grande que la demande pardon est
beaucoup plus grande que l'offre ce qui
fait en sorte à ce moment là que on part
vraiment d'un marché qui est en
surchauffe ce qu'on a présentement c'est
ce qu'on a présentement la schl a mis en
place un outil dans le fond un ratio qui
permet de dire si on prend les ventes on
les met sur les inscriptions
si c'est plus de 70% mais à ce moment
alors la région qu'on est en train
d'évaluer est en surchauffe donc
soixante dix pour cent de toutes les
inscriptions
c'est le nombre de ventes par rapport
aux inscriptions on est à combien dans
la grande région de montréal en ce
moment dans la grande région de montréal
en ce moment on est à 60 18 % 78 c'est
quand même donc c'est une vraie
surchauffe immobilière que nous
connaissons c'est une surchauffe
immobilière qui fait en sorte à ce
moment là que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile pour les premiers acheteurs
par exemple de se trouver quelque chose
dans la région de montréal et on se rend
compte que les autres régions les toute
la périphérie de montréal où l'impact
commence à se faire sentir leurs gardes
ont d'ailleurs un graphique que vous
avez préparé la grande région de
montréal par rapport aux autres grandes
régions
on voit clairement que montréal est en
surchauffe parce qu'on dépasse les 70%
mais pas très loin la région de gatineau
la région de sherbrooke et la région de
trois-rivières également effectivement
donc assez des régions qu'on surveille
de très près puis on a comparé avec
québec et saguenay pour qu'on puisse
voir l'accueil est vraiment
marge un peu plus grande mais on peut
voir que c'est pas seulement c'est un
problème qui est à montréal pour
l'instant mais on essaie de comprendre
qu'est ce que ça peut avoir comme impact
sur les autres régions administratives
ministre hâtives et les régions
métropolitaines métropolitaines de
recensement comment ça s'explique
conçoit comme ça dans des zones de
surchauffe
mais en fait l'économie va bien
l'économie très diversifiée dans la
région de montréal donc ça permet
d'avoir beaucoup plus d'argent pour
investir dans l'immobilier
l'autre chose c'est que le taux
hypothécaires sont très son très beau et
ça se maintient ce qui fait en sorte à
ce moment là que ça peut être très
avantageux d'acheter une maison ou de
prendre possession d'une maison et
l'autre point c'est vraiment le plein
emploi donc on est en mesure d'avoir des
gens qui travaillent ces problématiques
ce qui fait que c'est beaucoup plus
sympa ce moment-là d'acheter d'investir
dans l'immobilier
excellent contexte économique mais je
regardais saint-jean-sur-richelieu
rive-nord vaudreuil soulanges rive-sud
vraiment le cercle autour de montréal
grandit grandit de plus en plus et on
parle de surchauffe saint jean sur
richelieu on parle d'une surchauffe une
surchauffe dans cet endroit là aussi
donc c'est vraiment en train de prendre
une grande expansion faut comprendre que
beaucoup des migrants qui arrivent dans
la région de montréal qui sont pas
nécessairement en mesure d'acheter
donc ils vont acheter en périphérie il
ya beaucoup de vente des des gens qui
est des jeunes retraités qui décide de
vendre leur maison d'acheter donc c'est
des gens qui vont s'installer soit sur
l'île ou un peu à l'extérieur de l'île
je me rappelle il ya quelques années on
voyait les copropriétés les condos
grandir à montréal turin s'est arrêté là
il va y en avoir trop on vote en
surabondance on a l'impression qu'ils
aient eu complètement un revirement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans le monde
la copropriété mais c'est un peu ça
c'est vraiment dire il ya beaucoup des
migrants qui arrivent ya beaucoup de
gens qui achètent dans la région de
montréal et ça fait en sorte qu'une
surchauffe la surchauffe le plus
important présentement si on compare
l'unifamiliale avec le plex ou avec les
condos se rendent à dire les
copropriétés sont debout coup en
surchauffe
par la suite vous avez les maisons
unifamiliales qui le sont aussi mais pas
les plex
alors regardons les prix au chapitre des
prix quand même une euros ce
considérable quand on regarde le
graphique que vous avez préparé on voit
d'année en année une augmentation du
prix médian c'est la moyenne sur 12 mois
dans la région de montréal en 2014 à
2018 la tendance était à la hausse
mais depuis 2018 vraiment une
accélération de la hausse
une grande accélération si on compare on
était sur une période en 2014 et 2018
on est passé d'environ 270
il a 300 2000 donc 270 à 300 2000
exactement il en arrive à quoi 300 euros
on est rendu à 321 321 oui en une seule
année et demi à peu près exactement et
ce qu'on essaie d'évaluer c'est de
quelle façon ça va se traduire dans les
prochaines dans les prochains mois
essayez de comprendre
est-ce que ça va se maintenir et georges
russe un marché en surchauffe
mais c'est dangereux jusqu'à un certain
point je pense que c'est pour ça que on
essaie de voir comment elles comment on
peut faire pour le contrôler comment on
peut faire pour s'assurer que ça
devienne pas comme on a connu à toronto
ou à vancouver par exemple donc on veut
pas que montréal soit dans la même
situation pour l'instant c'est pas le
cas pour l'instant on dit en surchauffe
mais probablement qu'en 2020 devrait
avoir un déclin mais il devrait avoir
une progression beaucoup plus lente que
ce qu'on connaît présentement avec le
ralentissement de l'économie qui est
attendu également exactement au niveau
mondial ouais on sait pas ce qui va
arriver la vallée les relations des
états unis avec d'autres pays
donc ça peut avoir ça peut avoir un
impact au niveau du marché de montréal
et la région du québec donne est très
intéressante est important d'associer
merci beaucoup merci à vous